[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
postuler 30 fois a été rejeté
Je suis allé voir la police écoute non tu n'es pas
bon je suis allé voir tu sais même le KFC
quand le KFC est venu vérifier je dis tu
vois 24 personnes sont allées  pour le poste 23 personnes ont
accepté j'étais le seul mec
[Musique]
avant vingt ans être un bon
élève avant trente ans
ce n'est pas dans quelle entreprise tu vas c'est quel
patron tu suis de trente à quarante
ans tu dois penser très clairement
étaient  tu travailles pour toi quand
tu as 40 à 50 ans tu dois faire
toutes les choses pour lesquelles tu es bon quand
tu as 50 à 60 ans travailler pour les
jeunes de plus de 60 ans passer
du temps pour toi sur la taille de la plage
briller, je pense que dans 30 ans, les gens
ne travaillent que quatre heures par jour et peut-être
quatre jours par semaine
Jack et moi allons faire de petites
choses formidables pour les petites entreprises, ça parlera des
petites entreprises
[Musique]